oh
[Musique]
tu vois ce sol et guy breton visage et
ses sourires qui courent sur la plage
tous en irak en ce voilier qui part qui
traversent le ciel parole à tous on ira
les effets le vent tous on ira liberté
quand les hirondelles qui auront fait
les printemps et les deux ailes dans le
dos car tu même temps tous en ira même
toit et moi tous en ira trop tôt s'il
assume watrous sans me round même toit
et moi tous on ira demain que demain ses
mains de l'un d'eux demain
c'est loin c'est loin c'est ans
demande
de
s'élancer loin d'eux
[Musique]
et
demain et
c'est loin et est
et
c'est loin regarde là bas le soleil qui
s'effondre regarde le ciel comme c'est
beau quand iguerande s'en ira comme la
nuit reprend les ondes et ce voilier et
le tour c'est le monde te sentiras les
histoires c'est les comptes tous on ira
les retards et les montres les
hirondelles qui ne feront plus l'un
d'eux est l'envolée je les aimais bien
tous on ira même toit et moir tous on
ira trop tôt d'ici là ce mois tous on
ira au même toit et moi tu sentiras
demain recrutement sur un demain 2
deux marins c'est loin c'est loire se
rend demain
c'est loin c'est loin d'eux
dans l'ain demain 2
c'est loin c'est moi cela
le lendemain deux
c'est moi c'est un peu
et
notamment et
loin des
[Musique]
petits coups bas mon sauveur à lille où
nous que nos folies dalle qui elle bat
akonga du coaching auprès des tice le
talent des taux de quito dans ces îles à
tonneins et tico tico femmes s'avèrent
rallumer le mundo ils ont remis dans
lequel barack anglade tico tico pédo
discount aldi et aux banques et aux low
ses fils atone au sefi la tendance est
là oui demain ce film
[Musique]